[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing wormtail
aka peter pettigrew wormtail gets a bad
rap and has arguably the worst
reputation of the entire franchise with
perhaps the exception of umbridge
no one not even wormtells allies held
him in a very high regard and one of the
reasons that people looked down on him
was that they saw him as submissive and
weak voldemort and the death eaters
disrespected him never truly giving him
the time of day
wormtail was instrumental in voldemort's
resurgence so it's a testament to
voldemort's innocent nature and
wormtail's submissive nature that he
could disrespect him so openly
at one point wormtail was sent to
snape's house to assist him but snape
ended up treating him like his servant a
supreme gesture of disrespect i was
under the impression that the dark lord
sent you here to assist me
to assist you yes but not to serve you
drinks and to clean your house
wormtail was a british pureblood wizard
born in 1959 or 1960. he had pale skin
unhealthy hair that was constantly
falling out and blue eyes he was a
sniveling excuse for a man whose
loyalties only lay where there was power
and he did not value friendship or love
in the way that most do
despite serving both sides of the battle
at one point or another neither
respected him
and those that wormtail betrayed hated
him because he was morally an awful
awful person
and while i agree with the sentiment
that wormtel was a despicable person
morally i am not of the impression that
he was an untalented wizard
in my opinion wormtail is one of the
most underrated characters in the
franchise power wise as if we break
everything down we can see that he was
actually able to achieve quite a lot
magically was he the most powerful
wizard of all time definitely not but
were there worse wizards than him
certainly
many witches and wizards wrote off his
magical ability due to his appearance
and meek demeanor the truth is that
pettigrew was a talented wizard but he
was also equally mentally weak and
impressionable
i'm sure petaku didn't perform well at
school but this could have been for any
number of reasons and everyone knows
that many people struggle in their
respective fields in their formative
years
it's entirely possible that he was just
a late bloomer
i think that it would be safe to say
that petticrew's friends never truly
respected him and viewed him as a little
beneath them despite being the good guys
after years and years of being dismissed
and not taken seriously petty crew
simply hit a breaking point appointed
which he sought power independently from
those that he knew
when he turned to voldemort pettigrew
saw an opportunity to become his own man
voldemort probably saw that he was
decent at magic but also mentally weak
and he took advantage of that
james sirius and lupin were ultimately
good people but they were also arrogant
jerks in their youth and pettigrew who
was perpetually looked down upon by them
eventually made a choice as awful as it
was to betray them
his tale could easily be an allegory for
bullying and the bullied kid going down
the wrong path
pettigrew grew up in the shadow of
others
had historical circumstances been just a
little different it's not out of the
question that he might have really
flowered in a more independent
environment just a few years later
at last three of the rather pompous and
arrogant friends with which he'd spent
his teenage years
while at school professor mcgonagall
expressed that peter was less talented
than his friends going as far as to say
that he was hopeless at dueling
and while serving lord voldemort he too
denoted him as a poor wizard
but among his childhood companions the
marauders there really wasn't much of an
indication that he was significantly
less talented than any of them
and the other three sirius black james
potter and remus lupin were all very
talented wizards in fact wormtail would
go on to become far more versed in the
dark arts than any of them
opening up and expanding his magical
arsenal and taking it to another level
altogether so why does worm tail get
such a bad rap
jk rowling herself said the following on
this matter
it turned out that he was a better
wizard than they knew
referring to the marauders the truth is
that when peter was truly pushed he was
able to accomplish a lot
let's take a look at some of his
accomplishments
with help from the other marauders peter
was able to become an animagus at the
early age of 15.
hogwarts transfiguration professor
minerva mcgonagall
only achieved this feat at the age of 17
and she was under direct instruction
from transfiguration master albus
dumbledore this really speaks to how
impressive this feat was despite having
been helped by his friends
at the wagadu school of magic a school
known for its intensive focus on
self-transfiguration
students become anime guy by the age of
14.
peter attending a regular magical school
with no particular focus on
transfiguration achieve this one year
older
peter was of course an unregistered
animagus meaning that he did not report
his animega status to the ministry of
magic something that all animegai are
meant to do
this allowed him to abuse his ability
dumbledore freight it well when he said
that anime guy are usually people who
seek to avoid punishment when they broke
the law
in his animagus form pettigrew hid from
the order of the phoenix death eaters
and the ministry he was even able to
falsify his death
after escaping sirius after voldemort's
first defeat he was able to successfully
frame him for his crimes then fake his
own death simultaneously killing 12
people with one curse
after this he lived for years in his
animagus form a rat
patrick crew stayed in his animagus form
for 12 whole years something that i
can't imagine was an easy feat and
became the weasley family's pet rat
scabbers
in addition to becoming an animagus
which is an advanced form of
transfiguration pettigrew was also
versed in conjuration another extremely
advanced branch of transfiguration
conjuration which allows individuals to
transfigure an object out of thin air
was only taught to talented students at
the newt level
pettigrew uses conjuration in 1996 when
he produces ropes which bound harry
potter to tom riddle senior's grave it
has been stated that the only form of
transfiguration more difficult than
conjuration was human transfiguration
which he also achieved
potions peter under voldemort's
instruction was able to produce both the
rudimentary body potion and the
regeneration potion
the first potion allowed voldemort to
achieve his basic rudimentary form and
the latter returned the dark lord to his
former glory both potions were highly
advanced dark magical potions which
pettigrew would have had no experience
with
sure voldemort was probably a good
teacher but he still pulled it off
successfully and didn't pull a sheamus
finnegan pisa also helped barty crouch
jr to produce the polyjuice potion which
allowed crouch to assume the identity of
alistair moody
this leads us to peter's next skill
dueling despite professor mcgonagall
expressing in his younger years that he
was hopeless at dueling pettigrew went
on to become fairly successful in
numerous dueling endeavors in order to
obtain the ingredients necessary to
impersonate alistair moody pettigrew had
to try and trap moody which he did along
with barty crouch jr
alistair moody was a scottish pureblood
wizard and is considered by many to be
the most famous aura of all time
he was the order of the phoenix member
dark wizard catcher and warrior moody
served with great distinction during the
first wizarding war and lost an eye leg
and nose in battle against evil doers
moody is personally responsible for a
large number of the witches and wizards
in azkaban and this earned him quite the
reputation amongst the dark wizard
community this makes pettigrew's
achievement of capturing him all the
sweeter additionally though it wasn't
much of a jewel pettigrew makes quick
work of cedric diggory with evada
cadavra
though cedric was young and didn't see
it coming he was considered to be a
talented student and stood no chance
against wormtail
this also spoke to pettigrew's skill in
all manners of the dark guards a zavada
guidara is not a particularly easy spell
to cast
avada kadavra is one of the three
unforgivable curses and in order to
utilize it properly it requires extreme
concentration
additionally in 1981 the same year
pataku framed sirius for the death of 12
muggles he utilized a dark advanced and
powerful blasting curse
the curse was strong enough to murder 12
people destroy hundreds of feet of sewer
system and leave a 40-foot crater in the
ground
i'm certain that peter was far more
skilled in the dark arts than any of the
other marauders would have been in
addition to the above mentioned which
featured some of his most notable
accomplishments peter also helped to
produce and design the marauders map a
highly advanced piece of magic showed
extreme wand versatility seemingly using
any and all ones that he got a hold of
with no issue despite not yet winning
the one's allegiance and regularly used
non-verbal magic
ones and incantations generally help
witches and wizards to channel their
magic
allowing them to achieve a more accurate
potent results however truly powerful
witches and wizards are able to produce
magic regardless of these two factors
peter was one of those wizards
so as you can see pettigrew was able to
achieve a lot during his time in the
wizarding world i'm sure when it comes
to death eaters pettigrew is no snape or
bellatrix but he did end up becoming a
reasonably powerful wizard and that's it
for this video what do you guys think
i'm missing something let me know down
in the comment section below until next
time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live